[Music]
kind of applied to addy sex what should
I do
Joe what send an emoji okay
be cool welcome to the secret world
inside your phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming text we are
go for meth rap boot me miss what is
that I've got to get this phone fixed
this has never happened before and now
alex has made an appointment to wipe out
his phone it's Alex to leave the whole
world gets wiped out I'm not gonna run
away from this I made a mistake but I'm
gonna fix it I think we can make things
right you just have to go to a place
where no emoji has gone before
the cloud I know a shortcut through
smap's but no one's ever left our city
and they'll send box after us
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever candy crush I've never eaten
another piece of candy again Oh high
five don't do it don't you do it it's
already been in there once you decided
to stratify I got an idea we're running
out of time before the phone get swipes
you need to get the master password
access denied this might take a while
wait what access denied we're gonna have
to dance our way out everybody can dance
see ya
[Music]